une île au large de la côte de garde,
nous avons rendu les rétractions vivantes si
étonnantes qu'elles captiveront l'
imagination de la planète entière, soyez les
bienvenus,
par conséquent, cela dans le monde jurassique prend
vie, c'est comme voir Jurassic Park
devenir réalité,
tout comme se promener  les
bois il y a 65 millions d'années, Steven a eu
l'idée de faire un film sur notre
relation avec les animaux de notre planète en
ce moment les yeux sur moi
pour bouger chaque fois que nous avons dévoilé une
nouvelle attraction la fréquentation a augmenté qui a
demandé descend une route originale et
c'est une aventure à couper le souffle nous avons une
nouvelle attraction notre premier
hybride génétiquement modifié nous venons de faire un
nouveau dinosaure je ne serais pas une bonne idée
qu'elle a été conçue pour être plus grande que le
t-rex lorsque vous créez un animal pour votre
propre amusement  ça ne va pas bien pour les
humains tu as un atout hors du
confinement tu as 20 000 personnes
ils n'ont nulle part où aller un fan de
Jurassic Park je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité de s'assurer que y  ous
livrez quelque chose dont les gens qui ont
créé cette franchise seront fiers
nous poursuivons avec tout ce que nous avons
mon objectif avec ce film a toujours été
d'étonner les adultes pouvoir se sentir à nouveau comme des
enfants vous